[Musique]
vous vivez depuis 82 ans dans la forêt
depuis 82 ans vous faites des sabots
vous devez être le sol le dernier
sabotier à vivre dans la forêt oh oui
sûrement
ni vessel en ce moment mais dans le
temps où vit en famille dans l'es8 tout
le temps 2 3 4 5 vous pâtissier vous
même vos hutte où les faisiez-vous même
lutte
oui oui tout envoi à tout le moins comme
cela lui l'élite où tout autour l'étape
vous êtes jeune et mon père oui votre
père est né dans une hutte aussi oui oui
et vos enfants aussi oui
kanga garçons et et et tout le monde
habité dans la 8e c'est à dire qu'il y
avait dit oui
votre femme faisait la cuisine ah oui et
elle est connue
l'affichage et file à l'essai les a
qu'est-ce que vous mangiez dans le forez
ou du moins c'est dit je répondrai
abdallah chose comme ça est ce que les
médecins à l'époque venait dans la forêt
voire à non je n'ai jamais non non quand
je débute commencé à ouallam il cela il
faut faire la paix à 5 remake vous aviez
des remèdes aux beaucoup non des herbes
et celle décrochée à bas des tisanes des
sources comme ça quoi vous faites des
sabots depuis quel âge et puis d'auchan
depuis l'âge de 12 ans il commençait à
faire pour prendre mon unité avec votre
père mon père vous vendiez les sabots
acquis à l'époque à nous je travaille
avec une autre patte ont quoi et puis
tous les mois et vient dans le bois à
chercher des sabres et nous paye combien
coûtait une paire de sabots ya 40 ou 50
ans oh non j'ai donné loli le père le
chabot à 20 l'apprend wagon wheel qui
lie francs les alinéas la f1 il fallait
combien de temps pour faire une paire de
sabots à il faut les diam's et 3 8 à 3
heures de travail oui mais en pensant
déjà aux cayes de temps en temps
maintenant vous allez chez vos enfants
et chez vos petits enfants à la ville
ils ont la télévision ça vous l'avez
découvert il ya un an la télévision ya
pas plus d'un an vous regarder la
télévision
ça vous plaît
willow qu'est ce que vous aimez les
images
oui il est des matchs passés comprends
pas qu'est ce que guy il n'ya pas
longtemps vous tend les français
monsieur moelle ils n'ont évolué
après que commencer comprendre quelques
mots j'ai 50 ans vous aviez 50 ans dont
cinquante ans vous avez parlé uniquement
le breton abritant qu'est ce que vous
préférez vivre dans un village où vivre
comme ça en forêt à saigner les forêts
il ya plus beaucoup de sabotier comme
vous qui vivent fort et maintenant c'est
fini c'est fini ap
vous n'avez pas un petit peu de regrets
qui n'est pas d'autre que vous n'ayez
pas de camarades comme vous aviez du
camarade dans le temps par an le nom
vous est content tout seul
oh oui
[Musique]